serenity and firefly if talking about
reboost would you would you you've been
asked a million times but would you do
that why wouldn't i do that it was one
of the best things that ever happened to
me now let me ask you because i've read
an article or something that says you
know this was the best acting job i've
ever had i think that was for firefly i
mean yesterday
yes at the time yeah
right yes
but my question is and you could just
divert if you want
what if they do these projects without
joss whedon
oh that would be heartbreak
because he created them yeah those are
those are his
how can you
well because of all the controversy and
all the stuff that
happened what's your take on that or
would you rather not speak
um i just wonder correct me listen i
i read that article yes um nowhere in
there at any point in time did he
mention
firefly
i
you know i
i hadn't entirely that was not my
experience with that man
what was your experience
funny
self-deprecating incredibly talented
maybe a little haunted
i mean right listen by his own admission
that guy's a work in progress and i
appreciate that
um
i i would work with josh again in a
second
i would work with him again in a second
and has he ever hinted about doing one
of these projects again
nathan
i mean how do you feel about uh
we we talk we joke we we fantasize if i
if i say anything too solid it'll go
crazy i mean i hate being responsible
for that crap
but
yeah but um
that's
an entire cast and crew of people who
had a fantastic job on that job it was
short-lived so it was
it didn't have an opportunity to decide
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
you know
were you surprised how that didn't have
legs that it didn't although fans just
to this day eat it up the the fan base
is remarkable so it did have legs i was
surprised
at how we were treated
i was surprised at how it ended i kept
saying guys don't worry we're telling
great stories people love this it's a
good show we're doing everything right
don't worry and then you cancel that's
about an hour later someone's
heartbreaking oh my gosh yes oh my god
it was terrible
and then
this whole
fan base i mean a huge fan base you go
to cons how many people what percentage
want to talk about serenity or firefly
you know i'll tell you i i couldn't i
mean
at this point you have so many projects
people really rarely go to just the one
so they'll list off a bunch but i'll to
that i'll say this i used to be able to
spot a firefly fan i used to say oh
is it the shirt
is it the uniform typically a
generational thing uh yeah you you'd
think you would know
and uh
that's now a thing of the past i no
longer have that gauge where i can say
oh that's a castle fan and that's a
fireplace fan
you